all right that was the president from
the White House earlier today responding
to the deadly attack in Chattanooga
tennessy joining me now is the director
of jihad watch Robert Spencer an
investigative journalist and CEO of
American Media Institute Richard Miner
is back with us Robert let me ask you
about a report that you put out earlier
today and and I think you were quoting
the Associated Press if I'm not mistaken
about a potential Islamic State tweet
warning about the attack and that it was
posted at 1034 that turned out not to be
true well it's a it was a genuine tweet
but it seems that it came from the
Pacific time zone and so it was uh
almost certainly posted after the attack
and not during or before and so the
initial reports were inaccurate about
that but the larger question in this
Sean remains and that is the fact that
last September the Islamic State put out
a an explicit call for attacks on
military personnel in Western countries
and that that attack that that call was
heed in Canada in France just this past
week and elsewhere around the world and
so the investigators I think would be
seriously remiss if they didn't look for
some Islamic State connection here
whether the uh the shooter here was
inspired by the Islamic State or
explicitly directed at this point it's a
distinction without a difference the
Islamic State wants military men to be
attacked in Western countries this was
an attack by on military men in Western
countries you know Richard I I think in
many ways Robert's right we live in a
very politically correct World um you
look at the circumstances here the call
by ISIS to attack military installations
it seems to be at least the number one
thing I would be looking at your
thoughts absolutely I mean against those
who warn about the dangers of profiling
there certainly are real dangers to
profiling you have to ask the question
why is it that so few of these killers
seem to be named after Roman Catholic
saints I mean there is a connection here
we know from the Fort Hood shooting and
similar shootings that often there is
Direction either out of al-Qaeda and
Yemen or out of Isis or out of other
radical salafi or Islamic radical groups
uh certainly I think investigators are
going to be looking at his emails and
his other electronic communications it's
also instructive that the two blog posts
that he's ever posted according to the
Daily Beast both refer to Islam from a
very radical perspective the other thing
investigators should be looking at too
the videos of these facilities over the
past week often these kinds of attacks
are rehearsed days in advance and it's
also possible if there's video of him
rehearsing this attack there may be a
passenger in the car and that would
Point investigators in the direction of
other accomplices all right Robert
Richard thank you both for being with us